MALE SPEAKER: Thank you
everybody for coming,
despite there being a
Spain/Netherlands match
in an hour.
So that's really brave
of you to come here.
And I don't know how many of you
were there for the last year's
talk by Radhanath
Swami, here at Google.
OK, just one.
So I don't know if you
heard about this book.
It's called "The Journey Home."
He's the author of that book.
So we invited him as part of
the "Authors at Google" series
to give us some
wonderful insights
he has from his life's journey.
Actually this book, even though
it's called a autobiography,
it covers mostly two
years of his life,
when he was a teenager.
But those two years
are worth going through
in depth, as you
can see what goes
on in the mind of a spiritual
aspirant, who was a teenager
and just steadfastly had
this one goal in mind,
to know the meaning of life.
And then with so much passion
and integrity to himself,
how he found that goal.
And then the rest of his life
is a dedication to that goal.
So that's what brings him
here today for this topic
on integrity or influence
without affluence,
the power of integrity
and authenticity.
So basically the reason
he chose that topic
is because that's the
essence of his personality.
I've known him for like 17
years and heard his lectures
and talks.
And he's a very humble person.
And the last thing
I could expect
is that he would write
a book about himself.
Why would a monk, who is so
humble, write about himself?
Normally, people read books as
a ego trip or just to show off.
But then the reason
he wrote this book is
to show how one could be
successful if one first
used one's own calling of the
heart despite all obstacles
and remain committed
to that goal.
So that's the real
essence of his being.
And the book here,
"Journey Home,"
there's a bunch of
copies available
at the subsidized rate.
So you can pick up
one when you go.
And then we also have this
program called "Atma."
They have some flyers out there.
So this, of course, is
on the "Bhagavad Gita."
Some of us are doing here.
We are doing these talks
as part of these courses.
So if you're interested, you
can pick up one of the flyer
or go to go/atma.
So with that, give
a warm welcome
to Radhanath Swami for Google.
[APPLAUSE]
RADHANATH SWAMI: [CHANT]
It is my great honor and joy
to be with all of you today
at this most
important place that
affects the whole world in
every moment, the headquarters
of Google.
With power comes a tremendous
amount of responsibility.
The power of wealth,
the power of knowledge,
the power of fame,
the power of having
skills, when these, from
a spiritual perspective
on these blessings,
are entrusted to us,
we have a great
responsibility just
beyond our own little circle
or reference of reality.
Because at every moment,
our thoughts, our words,
and our actions are influencing
the world, the universe,
and the creation.
If anyone knows these
subjects from a scientific,
technological perspective,
it's all of you here at Google.
There's a saying that you
can tell how rich you are
by counting how many things
you have that money cannot buy.
Recently, I was at
the House of Lords
in London, in the
British parliament.
And I spoke that one little
sentence and everyone applauded
because everyone
there had so much.
And the more you have, the more
you realize how these things
cannot buy us happiness.
It is said in a human-evolved
society of consciousness,
people love people
and use things.
But in the world we
live, all too often
people love things and
use people to get them
or to keep them.
There can be no inner
fulfillment in such a life.
The "Bhagavad Gita" tells
that real intelligence
is when we find satisfaction
within ourselves.
And then, instead
of desperately,
passionately trying to get
stuff to give us satisfaction,
we use all these
things in this world
to share the
satisfaction we have.
That's a fulfilling life.
When we have that inner
peace, that inner love,
that interconnection
to grace, then it's
a foundation that we can
build our whole life upon.
If we build a house-- let us
take this wonderful building
in the Google
headquarters, for example.
It's a wonderful building.
It has beautiful
architecture, and very nice,
modern design, and a lot
of technologies in it.
But very few people
will come and say
this building has a
fantastic foundation.
Because foundation is not
what is seen externally.
But the reality is the
foundation holds up everything.
Without the foundation,
the whole building
will crumble in a time
of crisis or storm.
So to have actual
happiness in this world
is not on the basis of
what's happening around us.
Because things are
always changing.
It's the nature of the world.
Happiness, distress; honor,
dishonor; pleasure, pain;
health, disease;
success, failure;
victory, defeat, like two sides
of a coin, these dualities
are inseparable.
And if our happiness
is dependent on getting
the side of the
coin that we prefer,
then it's very tottering--
but if we can find happiness
beyond that.
I sometimes tell a story.
It's in this book.
I was sitting on the back
of the Ganges River one day.
It was summer, the
month of May in India.
It was probably 120 degrees,
with not a single cloud
in the sky.
And no one-- even though
this was a very holy place,
the place where the
Ganges, and the Yamuna,
and Saraswati, three rivers
meet, because of the heat,
one was there except me.
If you go there
during Kumbhmela,
which I did last
year, on one day
there was 25 million people
in that spot, all trying
to bathe at the same
time, in the same place.
So there's a price
to pay, the heat,
that I had it all for myself.
[LAUGHTER]
And as I was sitting
there, I saw a hawk
hovering down in the sky.
He had long, extended
wings, brown, golden-white.
And I saw his yellow eyes
intensely gazing down
into the river.
He was circling,
lower, lower, lower,
until he was just a
few feet above my head.
And I saw his pointed
beak and very sharp claws.
And he looked hungry.
And I looked like the only
piece of meat around actually.
[LAUGHTER] So I was quite
awake in my meditation.
[LAUGHTER]
Suddenly, [EXPLOSION], he
dove right into the water,
head first.
He went underwater.
And [SPLASHING] the
water was-- there
was something going on
under there, a splashing,
and splashing, and splashing.
Then the hawk emerged
from under the water.
And in his claws was a
fish, about one foot long.
It was only a few
feet away from me.
I could look right into
that little fish's eyes.
He was flapping desperately.
Maybe it was a
she, I don't know.
[LAUGHTER]
But that fish eyes look
totally shocked, disoriented,
and desperate.
And as the hawk was taking him
higher and higher into the air,
I was thinking that fish
was probably just having
a regular old day,
like the rest of us.
He was swimming around with his
friends and with his relatives,
and looking for some food,
and finding food, and playing,
and swimming upstream, and
downstream, and across stream.
And just like any
other day, enjoying
the beautiful underwater
vegetation of the Ganges.
And suddenly, the hawk of fate
ripped that little fish out
of its complacency.
And now, he was helpless
and about to die.
I was just about 19 years
old when I saw this.
And it was a time in my
life when I was really
searching for
meaning and purpose.
And every little
thing I was seeing-- I
was looking for messages.
And in the Bible, it says
seek and you shall find.
Knock [KNOCKING] and
the door will open.
If we're looking
for wisdom, it's
revealing itself to us
everywhere and in everything.
So this was a life-changing
experience for me,
although we probably see
things like this every day.
I was thinking that
that hawk of fate
can shake any one of us out of
our comfort zone at any moment.
That's just the nature
of life in this world.
But if that fish
was swimming deeper,
the hawk could not reach it.
And similarly, if we
find our happiness
in a deep place
within ourselves,
in the values, the integrity, in
the compassion that we live by,
nothing could
shake the happiness
because it's beyond
all the dualities
and changes of the world.
The world is said to be
a mirror of our own state
of consciousness.
No two people see the
same thing the same way.
People like to be objective.
But I'm about 64 years
old and in my experience,
no one could really
be objective.
[LAUGHTER] To a
certain extent we can,
but we're all seeing
through different lenses
of our consciousness.
When the Sun rises,
even in our own life,
every day we're seeing a
different kind of sunrise.
It's the same Sun planet.
But depending on our
mood, one day we wake up
and we see the
sunrise and we think,
god, another day
I have to struggle
with this problem
and that problem.
I wish I could just go to sleep
or just take some intoxication
and forget who I am.
Yes.
And another day we see
the Sun and we think,
oh, so many opportunities.
I'm going to do this today.
I'm going to do that today.
And another day we see
the Sun, and we think, oh,
how beautiful nature is.
So everyone is seeing
in different ways
at every moment,
what to speak of,
different people with
different experiences.
It's like I just coming
into the Google headquarters
and I saw these
beautiful flowers.
And at the beginning,
I was thinking, oh,
how nice these flowers.
And I was thinking I'd
like to take this flower
and offer it to my beloved lord.
And then, I started
getting some kind
of experience of hay fever.
[LAUGHTER] And I was seeing the
flower in a very different way.
I was saying I want to
get away from that flower.
I wish this flower didn't exist.
It's going to make
me sneeze and then
I'm going to be sneezing
during the lecture
and everything like that.
[LAUGHTER]
So things are so relative
and we are so subjective.
And in a certain way, we
should try to be objective.
But we are subjective.
We're all seeing
the world according
to the lens of our values,
of our particular attitude,
of what we're striving to
achieve in life, and of all
of our past experiences in life.
For some people, when they see
a drug addict, it's despicable.
For another person when
they see a drug addict,
they have such deep,
deep compassion.
They'll do anything for
that person to help them out
because they've been
through it themselves.
So what is the reality?
The reality is a truth.
But how we respond to it
becomes our inner reality.
And in this sense, the
Vedas, and particularly
the "Bhagavad Gita," explain
how we can subjectively
transform our objective
experiences in this world
by understanding some
basic principles of how
the world works.
There it is explained.
There are three gunas or
three modes of nature.
And these modes,
they're like colors.
And different
combinations of colors
create so many other colors.
But they're basic principles
of material creation
that influence
literally everything
within the creation-- like that.
Thank you, thank you.
Sometimes that helps
keep people alert.
I didn't mean to do it.
But still it had that effect.
[LAUGHTER]
There's the modes of goodness,
passion, and ignorance.
And the "Bhagavad Gita"
explains how they affect us
and how actually we come under
the influence of these modes
according to the choices
that we make in our lives.
When we make those choices,
then we acquire those qualities.
And then we become more inclined
to make those same choices
again, and again,
and again, and again.
But still we have
free will to come
to a higher aspiration
and attitude in life.
Let us take an example
of the gita of charity.
The "Bhagavad Gita" says
charity in the mode of goodness
is giving the right people the
right thing, at the right time,
in the right place,
so everyone benefits.
Charity in the mode of passion
is to give something to someone
so that I get tax breaks and
I get fame and popularity
by giving to somebody else.
Charity in the mode of ignorance
is giving the wrong thing
to the wrong person, at the
wrong time, in the wrong place,
in such a way that
it's actually harmful.
Our disposition in life--
let us take, for example,
our occupation-- how
the choices we make
affect our relationships
with other people
and with the environment
around us, which
is a very, very important
concern in the world today.
In our work, the way
we perform our work,
the way we interact
with people in our work,
and the way we utilize
what we gain from our work,
in the mode of goodness, we're
looking at a broad picture.
We're not just seeing
the immediate thing.
We all have to
focus on something
immediate,
accomplishing something,
a project or whatever it may be.
But to see it in the
broader perspective--
how am I going to do it in
a way that it's actually
going to bring out real
inner fulfillment to me,
real happiness to others, and
real prosperity for my cause.
That's the mode of
goodness, to really look
at the broader picture.
The Vedas explain there
is preyas and sreyas.
These are two types of
activities, and consciousness.
Sreyas is that what
we do, what we speak,
we are thinking
of how it is going
to affect the overall
present and future
and everyone involved.
And preyas is how
it affects me now.
It's like most
children, they really
don't like to go to school.
Some children do, but I didn't.
I just wanted to play.
In those days, in the 1950s,
in Illinois where I grew up,
we all played in empty lots.
And we played baseball,
and soccer, and football,
and all these games
in empty lots.
And we could just play forever.
And then my mother says it's
time for school-- and, ptth,
what a waste of time.
Now, I didn't have
the intelligence.
But my mother had
Because you can play all day and
be happy now, but in the future
your life is going to be
in destitute and misery
because you're not planning.
So going to school is sreyas.
Playing all day is preyas.
But this actually
applies at every stage
of our life, in whatever we do.
The decisions we're
making, what we're doing,
and how we're doing
it is going to affect
the future quality of my life
and those people around us
and the environment around us.
So the mode of goodness,
or sattva guna,
is to have knowledge and
to apply that knowledge,
to take serious responsibility
for the spiritual, social,
individual, and collective
welfare of everyone.
That is the mode of goodness.
The mood of passion
is more the drive
to accomplish something,
centered primarily
around the principles
of I, me, and my,
and not really considering who
I am, what values are there,
or how it's going to affect the
environment or other people.
And the mode of ignorance
is when the mode of passion
deteriorates to the point where
our actions and our choices
are insensitive to the pain of
others, where we can justify
cruelty, we can justify
tearing other people down
to bring myself up.
We can justify destroying the
ecology and the environment
for generations in
the future just so
that I can accomplish
something for me now.
That's the mode of ignorance.
Wisdom is to balance.
Because all of us, we have
to act with passionate.
We have to strive to
accomplish something.
Whether we're engineers, or
scientists, or educators,
or we're in business, or
investment, or politics,
or whether we're
farmers, or even if we're
little swamis like me, we
want to accomplish something.
We need a drive
to accomplish it.
Wisdom is to balance this
passion with goodness,
with the vision of
a larger picture,
the social/spiritual
responsibilities that we
have in everything we do.
If we do not balance
passion with goodness, then
by nature's own course it
will be affected by ignorance.
Just like when a
river is flowing,
if you don't swim upstream,
you're going to go downstream.
You can't stay where you are.
Yes?
You ever be in a river?
You can't just say, OK, I'm
just going to rest and be here.
If you rest, you go [INAUDIBLE].
You're either going up or down.
So similarly, passion either
has to be balanced with goodness
or it's going to be
degraded by ignorance.
And as human beings, this is
the responsibilities we have.
And inner fulfillment
actually comes
by making choices based on these
higher principals, these higher
values.
I was recently at a marriage.
And they asked me to speak.
[LAUGHTER] It was in Southern
California and the people
getting married were lawyers.
So there were all these
lawyers and judges
and everyone at the marriage.
So I was saying a little
prayer, what should I say?
And sometimes
simple things come.
And I said all kinds of things.
But the one thing
they liked the best
was just the personal example.
My nephew is here.
His name is William, his
grandmother and grandfather,
who happen to be my
mother and father.
When I was about
eight years old,
I was just sitting on my
mother's bed, in her bedroom.
And she was looking
in the mirror
and putting mascara on her eyes.
Because this was in the 1950s.
And maybe-- I'm kind of out
of touch with these things
these days.
But I guess people still
put mascaras on their eyes.
So she was doing that.
And I was just watching.
And for me, this was like
the best television show,
just watching my mother
do this, something simple,
because of affection.
And then she turned to
me and said something
I'll never forget.
She said, everyone loves your
father and everyone loves me.
But we don't love
each other any more
and we have decided to separate.
An eight-year-old
boy hearing that-- I
don't know how
other people think,
but it created such
a trauma in my mind.
It was unimaginable.
It was inconceivable.
I felt so insecure, so unstable.
It was as if the whole world
had just fallen away from me
and I was just kind of
dropping into nowhere.
I couldn't say a word.
All I could do was cry.
And she looked at me and
she couldn't see a word.
She started to cry.
And then I ran away.
And she didn't
know where I went.
I ran down the stairs, out
the door, down the block.
And I just kept running.
That evening when my father
came back from work--
and he was struggling
because at that time he was--
did you ever hear of the Edsel?
He owned a dealership of Edsels.
So he was having many
challenges on many levels.
[LAUGHTER]
So he came home and
came into the bedroom.
And my mother and
father closed the door.
And I knew what they
were going to talk about.
So I secretly put
my ear to the door.
Nobody knows this.
And I heard my mother tell my
father what happened to me.
There was total silence
for about a minute.
And then I heard them say
we're going to work this out.
We're going to stay together.
We're going to work this out.
We have a higher
purpose to achieve
than just our relationship
with each other.
And they did.
And it wasn't easy for them.
But as the years
went by, I hardly
saw anywhere in the world such
a loving, respectful, and united
relationship between two
human beings as they had.
When my mother passed away,
they were married 58 years.
And when I think
of that incident,
I think the love and the
fulfillment that they achieved,
it wasn't because they were
thinking I, me, and mine.
They developed a relationship
based on a higher principle
that was beyond either of them.
And because they
took responsibility
for that higher principle,
a deeper fulfillment,
a deeper love than anyone could
imagine was given to them.
A couple years ago, I was with
my very dear-- my best friend,
[HINDU], who is
sitting here today.
He's the leader of
the Vaisnav community
in this part of California.
And every year, we take a
walk through the Muir Woods.
Whatever our schedules are,
we make this a priority, just
the two of us to walk
through this redwood forest
and just reflect about life,
and reflect about the year that
has passed, and reflect
about our future and really
reevaluate things.
Have any of you
been to Muir Woods?
Please raise your hands.
When we see those
gigantic redwood trees,
it's such a natural environment
that it does something to us.
[LAUGHTER] It induces
certain reflection
into higher realities
beyond ourselves.
One of the reasons is
these trees are so big
and we're so small.
And these trees, some of them
are 1,000 or 2,000 years old
and we'll be lucky to
live 80 or 90 years.
So when we really compare
ourselves to the trees,
these trees are
quite substantial.
[LAUGHTER]
A few years before that, I
brought a group of teenagers
to King's Canyon, where
the biggest Sequoia trees
and redwood trees
in the world are.
And we went to the largest
tree on planet Earth.
It's called General Sherman.
It's about 2,200 years old.
And it's gigantic.
If you hollowed it out
and put water in it,
I think you could have enough
water for a family of four
to take a bath for 12 years.
It's a big tree.
And we're just like little
insects to that tree.
And I asked the teenagers,
if General Sherman, who
has lived for 2,000 years,
could give a message
to humanity, what would he say?
And some of the boys--
you know how boys are.
[LAUGHTER] They were
saying all these kind
of ridiculous, humorous things.
But there was one girl.
Her name was-- I think
Lakshmi, American girl.
She started to speak.
And with her first
words, she began to cry.
And then she talked.
The way she spoke-- you've
heard about this concept
of channeling.
Well, it seemed like
that tree was channeling
through her [LAUGHTER]
because she was speaking
with such conviction
and such depth.
She was only about 15 years old.
She had the voice of the tree.
She said, why are you
humans so foolish?
I've been here before any
of you white people ever
came to this continent.
I've been here at
the time of Jesus,
at the time of the rise and
fall of the Roman Empire.
I've been here through
the Renaissance,
through World War I and
World War II, the Civil War,
the Vietnam War, the Korean War.
I've seen what you've done to
the skies, and to the oceans,
and to the Earth.
Why are you always fighting?
Why are you always
exploiting nature?
exploiting each other?
Why so much greed?
She said, don't you see, you're
only here for a couple years.
Your life is so short.
Why can't you learn to
cooperate on a higher principle?
She was crying, thinking
of what the tree was
seeing humanity doing.
So when I was walking with
[HINDU] in the Muir Woods,
I was reflecting on
all these things.
And then we came across
a group of tourists,
who were in a circle
around the park ranger.
And as we were walking
by, the park ranger said,
I am going to tell you
the underground secret
of the redwood forest.
Now having been a teenager
in the 1960s in America,
I still have a
spontaneous attraction
to underground things,
especially secrets.
He said, now please listen
carefully because this is-- it
changed my life in a special
way hearing this park ranger.
Usually I expect
to change my life
by listening to some
scholar of the Vedas,
or some preacher of the
Bible, or some great yogi.
But my life changed,
listening to a park ranger.
He said that in the Muir
Woods, the soil is very loose.
It doesn't have much stability.
And it's hilly, which makes
the stability even less.
For a tree to grow
high and survive,
it requires deep roots.
The redwoods-- the
roots do not grow deep.
They don't grow deep at all.
So how are these trees
surviving 1,000, 2,000 years,
through numerous
massive earthquakes
here, through frigid blizzards
in the winter, though
incredible windstorms?
And they just keep growing
higher, and higher, and higher,
higher than any other living
being in the entire planet.
How do they survive?
Then he stopped speaking
and let us all to imagine.
It seemed like such
a contradiction.
Then he explained how the
roots of the redwood trees,
they may not grow down deep.
But underground,
they grow outward.
And each root is searching for
the root of another redwood
tree.
And as soon as they come
together, they embrace.
They entwine around each other
and form a permanent lock.
All the roots of the trees
are looking for other trees
to make that relationship with.
And in this way, the little baby
trees that are so vulnerable--
the big, giant, ancient
trees provide their roots
for the baby trees to
wrap their roots around,
to give them their full support.
And even the giant
trees, they're
so vulnerable because
they're so high.
But all the other
trees in the forest
directly or indirectly
are interconnected.
And they're all giving
support to each other.
From a human perspective,
the roots of our existence
is very much in our affection,
in our love, in our concern,
in our care.
And when we reach
out to actually see
this larger picture, of how
it's not about I, me, or mine,
it's about us.
The "Bhagavad Gita" defines
wisdom-- [SANSKRIT].
The true wisdom is to see every
living being with equal vision.
Because beyond these three modes
of nature, the "Gita" explains,
there is the divine
state of consciousness.
Of understanding beyond
this ever-changing world
and beyond this
ever-changing mind,
there is the witness that is
within us, the true self, that
in Sanskrit is called the Atma.
So call it the
soul, or the spirit,
or the living force, or the
source of consciousness.
That conscious force is
seeing through our eyes,
and hearing through our
ears, and experiencing life
through our brains,
and through our hearts,
and through our bodies.
When we're tiny, little babies,
we have certain desires.
We have a certain
type of little body.
And now, most of us have
very different bodies.
And our minds are
thinking very different.
We're not thinking
about our mother's milk
any more, like we used to.
So everything's changing.
But still we're the
same person who's
witnessing life through
all these transformations.
Who am I?
A driver in a car takes
good care of the car,
but understands that he
or she needs something
more than gasoline for himself,
gives the gasoline to the car,
but I need something else.
What are the needs of
the soul, the true self?
To love and to be loved, that's
the basic fundamental need
for everyone.
And love is beyond selfishness.
To love is to care.
To feel love is
to feel cared for.
And the origin of that love
according to the "Gita"
is the soul's relationship
with the Supreme Soul, who
is called by many
names, sometimes
God-- in our tradition,
Krishna or Rama.
When we tap into that inner
truth of who we really
are and we experience that
love, that compassion,
then whatever we
may do in our life
is an expression of that
love and our compassion.
And when we understand
who we really are,
we can actually understand
the equality of all beings
because we see that spiritual
essence wherever there's life.
Whether a person is black,
or white, or red, or yellow,
or brown; or male or
female; or whether one is
from the East or the
West; whether one
is a Hindu, or a Muslim,
or a Jew, or a Jain,
or a Christian, or a Sikh, or
a Zoroastrian, or an agnostic,
or an atheist; whether one
is a human, or an elephant,
or a cow, or a dog, or a cat,
or a redwood tree, [LAUGHTER]
we see that life is sacred.
And when we start that life
force within ourselves,
we naturally will
respect that life force
wherever it is being seen.
And then there is this
higher fulfillment.
There is this higher purpose.
Which creates an
integrity that none
of the storms of this world
or the inevitable changes
can shake us, the integrity of
compassion, based on wisdom,
based on love.
That is within us.
And all the great
spiritual paths
are ultimately meant
to reconnect us
to that inner essence,
wherein we can really
find a foundation, where
we could find those roots.
And we could learn to reach
out together, to respect
each other, to honor each
other, to love each other.
And to reach out toward
all living beings
and to Mother Nature herself
in that spirit of compassion.
Google, perhaps more than any
other company in the world,
has mastered and perfected
the science of networking--
and if here we could
find that inner essence.
And I have heard there are many
projects that really are being
designed here at Google on
the foundation of these higher
principles.
And I thank you for that.
And I'm so grateful that you
have given me this chance
to speak these words today.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
MALE SPEAKER: Thank you
so much Radhanath Swami
for such a wonderful talk.
We'll have a book signing now.
And also before that, we'll
have a nine-minute Q&A
because the room
is booked at 2:00.
So if you want to
continue to hang around,
there is a micro-kitchen here.
So we'll have Radhanath
Swami go there.
And you can get signatures
of the books, "Journey Home."
They're available for a
subsidized price of like $10.
And you can also have
any personal questions
answered there.
So for next nine minutes,
we'll have Q&A here.
We'll pass around the mics.
You can just raise your hand.
AUDIENCE: In your
lecture, you said
that we can temper our
passion with goodness, rather
than sliding down
to moral ignorance.
So [INAUDIBLE], can you
elaborate more on how can
we practically do that
in our daily lives?
RADHANATH SWAMI:
The association we
choose to connect with when
we associate with people who
enlighten us, when we associate
with activities that enlighten
us, the books we read,
the entertainment we find,
the people we keep company
with, it very much affects
our values and our choices.
And that association
is very important.
And that's also why a regular
spiritual practice keeps
us very strongly connected
to these higher principles--
ultimately, the
principle of God's grace.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
RADHANATH SWAMI: You're welcome.
In our tradition, we chant God's
names to keep that connection.
MALE SPEAKER: Any
other questions?
AUDIENCE: Thank you so much.
I thought your
talk was beautiful.
I so resonate with it all,
especially with nature
and respecting all life.
What does a typical day look
like for you, your schedule?
RADHANATH SWAMI: Typical?
I have to search my
memories for a typical day.
[LAUGHTER]
Well, I'm not here
in the Bay Area,
[LAUGHTER] I usually arise
around 4:00 in the morning.
Because it's really a
precious time of the day.
In so many
traditions, especially
in our own traditions,
it's call Brahma-muhurta.
It's a very powerful
time of the day
to make spiritual connections.
And for focus and concentration
because kind of everybody
is sleeping.
And the passions of
the world around us
haven't really started
filling the environment.
And because we're just woken up,
our mind and our consciousness
is kind of like a blank slate.
And if we fill it with something
wonderful, with divine grace,
then throughout the
day we can actually
be energized, empowered,
to share that grace.
So we begin, we chant
the names of God,
usually for a couple
hours-- and prayer beads.
It's a type of meditation.
The mantra in my tradition
is Hare Krishna Hare Krishna
Krishna Krishna Hare Hare
Hare Rama Hare Rama Rama Rama.
We believe that all these
mantras or all these divine
sounds from all these great
spiritual traditions connect us
to that divine essence
and that grace within us.
And when I'm near it,
an ashram, we usually
have kirtan or
chanting together,
where, like the
redwood roots, we're
all united for one purpose,
to try to purify and cleanse
the world through
Krishna, God's grace.
And we study
scriptures together.
Then we take sacred food.
We're vegetarians.
And then we go and do our seva.
My seva is-- I live in
India actually, in Mumbai.
And we have many projects.
We have an ashram with
about 150 monks in it.
And we have the temple.
And many thousands of
people come every day.
And we have a congregation
of over 10,000 people.
And we have a 200-bed hospital.
And we have an orphanage
and we have a hospice.
And we have this one
project for feeding children
in the ghetto schools
in the Bombay area.
Because the number one reason
for illiteracy is hunger.
And instead of children going
and working-- child labor
or begging-- if they get
food, they'll stay in school.
So we are feeding about
410,000 children a day
now from our kitchens.
And we have an
eco-village, where
we have beautiful
cows and other animals
that we protect
throughout their lives.
And we build our buildings
out of the natural earth
that's around us, in
eco-friendly ways.
And we have natural
organic sewage refineries.
So every time you
flush the toilet,
you're actually investing
a wonderful contribution
into the community.
It takes longer than nine
minutes to talk about this.
But it's quite incredible.
By gravity and solar power,
you flush the toilet.
And it goes into a place.
And then it comes down
through these different herbs,
and roots, and
stones to filter it.
And it comes out
crystal-clear water.
We have thousands
of fruit trees.
And we grow our
own organic food.
But interestingly, we had
a yoga group from New York
just a couple months ago.
I was there.
And they looking at the papayas.
They were about this big.
And they were eating
the papayas every day.
They really liked it.
And then they came up to where
this sewage refinery was.
And papayas were about this big.
[LAUGHTER]
So on one lady yogi, she gave
a new name to our papayas.
She called them "poopayas."
So I kind oversee
these projects.
And I have a lot of meetings
and a lot of counseling.
We have thousands and
thousands of married couples.
And sometimes they
need counseling.
[LAUGHTER]
So that's the
typical day for me.
And then I usually give
lectures in the evening,
public lectures-- sometimes
in the morning too.
And then I take rest.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RADHANATH SWAMI: In Mumbai,
most of the congregational
and ashram and
temple activities are
funded by the
congregation itself.
Because within our
congregation, we
have a lot of teachers,
industrialists,
business people, a lot of
software engineers-- [LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Oh, I see.
RADHANATH SWAMI:
--believe it or not.
So everyone-- because
they're inspired,
we don't actually have too
much fundraising in that sense.
People just, out of
their own appreciation,
they want to support and give
because they're inspired.
And according to what
we get, we built.
And as far as some of
the more public programs,
like the feeding of the
children-- and the hospital
does a lot of programs-- because
cataracts are the number one
cause of blindness in India.
So we do thousands and thousands
of free cataract surgeries
in the villages, a lot of
education in the ghettos
and village schools for health.
So those things are
funded by just people
from all over the world,
who appreciate the cause.
And whatever we have, we
just do that much more.
But it's based on a
spiritual principle
that when we actually
come in contact
with our eternal
souls-- and "Bhakti"
means to awaken the dormant
love for God that's within us.
When you water the
root of the tree,
the water naturally extends
to every part of the tree.
So through our
spiritual practice
and through our seva,
or our services,
our aim is to actually
come in contact
with the infinite beauty
and sweetness of God's love
and be an instrument of
that love in whatever we do.
And I personally have found
when we live by that principle,
and reduce our ego and humble
ourself to that principle,
then everything in life becomes
magical, even the challenges.
And as the world moves, the
hands of time moves with it.
[LAUGHTER] I am deeply
grateful to all of you,
to spend this time with you.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]